i'm sure i'll get it
can't push
is this a chase scene am i literally
coming in on a tray scene jesus christ
thanks sick pig for subscribing i'm just
dying everywhere what the hell is
happening
oh oh this is where we got to last time
okay
just it must have also saved a little
bit further back
because i remember this i remember being
like oh no if you died and then i get
you out and you're not dead
and then i held your hand and we went
round in circles
hold my hand please
how is the audio do you need me to turn
anything down or up or
or is it good
well let's go oh you're gonna give me a
boost
so many rooms which one should we take
this one the most obvious one
wow that is one heavy duck okay so the
men in black were here
the narrative to this game is still
quite a mystery to me i'm not gonna lie
oh i like that the little puffy
particles coming up out of the bed when
i jump
oh there's so many small little things
that i love in this game
really appreciate all the things i can
throw
it's so satisfying right oh can i pick
up this um
present on the table no not you want the
present
nope okay
oh no no no
jesus christ i should be done with this
game by next week so you can join us
next week
let's go we don't need that shoe
oh it's a tv again
oh yeah i need to do my little thing
use my psychic powers of the analog
stick
nice
i don't feel like i do get closer each
time
oh oh oh oh
we're opening the door it's staring at
us what do we do now
oh it's pretty pretty pink
it's the minute black it's slenderman
[Music]
what is slenderman doing in this game
oh crap ask ah it's gonna be like the
ring it's gonna call out the tv
we need to go yeah give
give her your hand she wants your hand
no
oh my god
well oh my god
where did she go let's just
this is like literally a nightmare you
know when something's chasing you and
you just feel like
you have nowhere to hide where's she
hiding i can't hide there
get it get down
yes i did forget how to crouch there
don't
don't come at me
but it does feel like a video game oh my
god
it feels like a dream of course it feels
like a video game
well you just can't move fast enough you
feel like you're trying to tread through
water
okay okay we're making good time here i
feel like i should go where she's going
but i also don't trust at the same time
so
come on oh my god i don't like how slow
oh come here come here
no what do we do i the game won't let me
oh no
oh
um can i save her
are these symbols like were they written
to protect me i feel like they were
like a protection spell or something
is she actually gone now and i can't
save her
is that how wait do i go into the tv
well to save her oh
[Music]
cool
i don't even know really what that did
i can climb back up though i have a
flashlight no i don't
my flashlight's gone i guess i only used
it for the um
hospital place is was that what that
place was
gotta keep trying
so i'm just gonna keep trying all the
tvs until they become busted
so
no way
i think
what's supposed to do with this thing
see if i had six here we could help each
other
oh cool oh
i understand teleportation
yeah the the tv does sound really dream
like
soldier benji be
[Music]
i'm still so confused i'm like
is this just a normal kid it can't just
be a normal kid surely
whoop
with a great sense of balance
to be fair he has had a lot of practice
and when he's felt quite a few times
with me controlling him
i can hear something off in the distance
and it does not sound good
oh [ __ ] off
what did i say
don't tell me anything don't tell me
anything about the game no spoilers
please thank you
i'll try and work it out and then we can
have a we can have a little open
discussion about the game
uh when i'm finished
very snazzy
there's so many of this in the game it's
like people's bodies have just
i guess that is what's happened it's the
thin man just come out and like zapped
everyone
and then their clothes have just been
like but that didn't happen to her
she left with her clothes her clothes
weren't with her so
yeah maybe this theory is off tv control
guys i know what to do i know to grab
remote
can i turn you off now goodbye hello
so i wonder where you go then
i can't
is there anything i can grab around here
and move it
shush
because there's no way i can make i can
jump up there
oh [ __ ] i can okay fair enough i don't
know i could
grab the bottom of the light
uh do you want to jump up here
there's a letter there you can read it
hey yvonne oh eve sorry
evie son 18.
oh hey maria thanks for super chatting
that's nice here oh and uh
antoine i didn't see that one was that a
few seconds ago as well was that
no no that was a while ago that about
wait was that you
i'm so confused they just come up now it
says i didn't have a date for
valentine's day so i decided to invite
my mom out because she deserves it
but didn't this happen on valentine's
day i'm very confused
is that my um wait is this everything
i'm so confused hey can i play with you
guys no this is like an oh
these are old ones youtube what you're
doing
hey gamer with malcolm i think that's an
old one too handstand and silk's queen
yes it is an old one this is so weird
it's all right you guys are getting a
shout out again you deserve it
um so i'm just gonna see what's through
here and then i will
go back there
youtube on that
youtube's just given given previous past
shout outs
oh cool
everything's so dark oh i got a new hat
give me a hug guys gotta be hot
get a new hat exciting
i'm a policeman now
let's wear our new hat i'm a policeman
authority
oh
oh he's got such a cute head like
everything is so tiny
little nose
oh hello i'm back here again
[Music]
so what if i turn this one off and then
and then go through here we'll open up
let me go through a different type of
portal
[Music]
no what that block of wood was shaking
did you see it
ah i love this music
sounds like um stranger things
here we go
i actually i'm really liking this music
[Music]
how do i climb up it though oh know all
right about right we gotta get back up
and then we can use it as a jump
go check that i'll put it in the middle
a bit more
just before coronavirus happened um i
went to
a stranger things uh secret cinema
london experience and oh my gosh it's so
amazing
it was like it was quite expensive but
you paid to basically be in stranger
things it was like
they had um all the sets were there and
oh it was just oh this where the heck
where the hat was
and uh you just got to kind of like it
just kind of felt like you were part of
it it's really hard to explain
wait how did i get back up from here
did i use the tv oops
oh it's okay i can turn it back on
ah weird to think that i was surrounded
by a bunch of people
like loads of people and then a couple
of months later
bedridden for like a year
so weird
all right so they make a certain noise
when when you can travel through them as
portals
um and when you can't they they make
it seems like an array of different
noises
and i like the sci-fi one the best
video
there we go
and geronimo
nice
what happens if i turn off the tv will
she get mad at me
be like my mom like i was watching that
yes okay there's a hat here i don't
think it's for me though
so good um
[Music]
okay she's obsessed with that tv
but i'm gonna have to go to it aren't i
maybe i can lure her into the oven and
then cook her up
oy oven
can i open the fridge
what do you think would go well with um
demonic lady
i don't know why i just opened the
fridge
bye eb thanks for coming
oh that's the other tv
oh we have to go and try and get to the
tv now
fun times hey sam
i got chased by slenderman
how am i gonna
yeah i thought about closing the closing
turning off the tv when i was up here
but i don't think i can turn it off in
this room unless i
i guess because you have to be facing it
i can turn it off now and then climb up
here
what's she going to do
she's like i don't know what to do with
my life i'll just
oh she's watching the other tv yeah
oh this makes sense okay
i thought she was just gonna go wash the
dishes i was like this is really
um
derogatory i guess
i am woman i clean dishes
but now she just loves the tv hello
[Music]
hello doesn't care about me
what if i turn off the tv now
just goes back to the other one
like i'm wondering if this game is like
a social commentary
on either media and brainwashing
or something but then there's there's
definitely more going on than just that
reminds me of jim carrey taking over
everyone's mind in batman forever
wait wait was that when he was like
in that tight green suit like
really tight like uncomfortably tight
i think i remember that
okay i need to find a good hiding spot
maybe i can just climb
back down again once i turn up this one
oh my gosh he fell and then he just
disappeared
yes redhead also wearing gray yeah i
remember i remember
this little cane
hey clay oh
oh no don't fall
was it um what killed the dinosaurs
the ice age i missed the old batman
films they were really bad but like in a
funny way
uh-oh
it is like mind control isn't it
oh and this is because we saw loads of
people falling from the sky
this is what's happening
okay
[Music]
i'm gonna get ready to grab jump and
grab
good boy grab it
okay that's not a pleasant sound
what did i just do oh the water's
electrified okay i can't do this
but this is how we're going to defeat
whatever the hell is on the other side
of that door so just be careful
oh no
oh it's gonna just like randomly come
out at a time when i don't expect it to
run run run the [ __ ]
[Music]
this game is so good at like just
how do they know how do they know
to like get so close oh i'd love to talk
to the developers
because the amount of times that i've
like clenched
everything because i'm so scared that
i'm just about to be
dead and it's literally just on the edge
it's crazy hey
hbb
oh the timing in this game is so good
got some metal music wow
where am i hello policeman here
what
oh down the hatch
oh there's a something here like a naked
doll
hello naked doll
i know there's that switch but
what's this
that eye is everywhere it's it's
it's that one from um
from in the in the skies and on the
tower
bray hen wants me to open the briefcase
what what briefcase
was that briefcase in with the trash
oh this one maybe
oh what we have here
shite shite and more shite
was actually something i needed
do i give it to you do you want this
parcel
what the hell
that was so cool thanks for letting me
know that
that was so cool oh now
that's why the letterbox was opening
closing subtly ah this game
so many secrets i love it
oh oh is that all again okay
luckily i'm a small boy
oh
[Music]
hmm okay
but why
uh scared to go down again just in case
there's no way of getting back up
short of the game devs would have
thought of that
but maybe there's something down there
now ah
screw it i'm gonna go
so what happens
if i i die of course
of course i die i had a thought process
it was just the wrong
one
has the mail already been delivered yes
you've broken the game before i will do
it again
very true catches it's good to know it's
good to know
you know try everything
[Music]
okay so if i leave this down here
okay i think i might know what i might
know what i probably don't
know what i'm doing but i might know
i'm gonna start the elevator then run
into the tv come on
no no no dude no no no no yeah thank you
glad you can cancel that right now run
into the tv
oh good no
oh i missed it
ah it's fine i'll try again you you all
saw what i was trying to do there right
we'll do it this time
trying to get into this room here
the one with the duck
okay try this again
and we go and then start running forward
straight away this
i can't speak come on oh my god
seriously
he falls and then takes forever to get
back up
surely that's gonna be the way if we do
it though no no
no no no i want you to jump on it
thanks for coming nikki
oh how do i stop him like
falling over
i don't know maybe i just gotta try and
do it faster
come on come on come on come on come on
ah he turns the wrong way around
whoa that was weird
[Music]
so i'm not actually jumping i'm just
standing
like i'm falling
hey photo score how am i i'm alright
it's been a long week i'm very ready for
the weekend even though i'd be very busy
i'm moving house next weekend so i've
got to do my packing and stuff
but how are you okay
let's try the other way
go go go go go go go
okay here we go
cars
what's this a bunny
a really creepy girl
good oh
she was just leading me to where i was
supposed to go sorry
didn't mean to be that rude too
oh sorry i was reading the chat
i've had a long weekend starting now
until tuesday ah
sounds great
okay so let's be careful here
[Music]
okay
platform me in this game yeah it's hard
sometimes
can i go to you
whoops
you know what i should just try and get
to the dry patch instead of trying to
jump from the bloody bath
[Music]
idiot
i'm not even going to mention why i just
read this in the chat
is this game actually scary yes watch
guys what was it the third episode or
something that i just could not stop
screaming like
it wasn't put on it was actually
terrifying
honestly the scariest this has been the
scariest game i've played in a very
long time without a doubt
is there any way that i can lead her
into here and kill her
but without dying myself so
if i say
one here oh yes i can just grab the
toilet seat
okay good to know
because that's what i'm about to do
beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep
beep beep beep beep
die bish
yayans yes
she took all the uh all the electricity
out there's a
power outage damn it i wanted to use
that tv
why you do this
uh can i use this stall anywhere else
it's very dark in here i can't really
see anything
it's grandma oh damn you killed grandma
i'm sorry it was self-defense
[Music]
must be a really good film
hello can i watch i want to watch
movie too
they really don't care about me
they do they do care so i'll just stay
out that way
and everything will be okay
another madness suit
i think there's something maybe up there
yeah i can't tell
sorry to anyone's ears
you know what to expect when you come to
a jagman extreme or if it's your first
time then
uh i'm i'm very sorry because you
probably didn't know what to expect
dinner i should have won
oh toys
hey gaming with malachi where's the uh
alert for this one then
there it is thank you
okay i think there might be something up
here so i'm just gonna put the trolley
like here only because i see
a dog peeing and it makes me think
there's something up there i don't know
why
whenever i see like odd
decals or whatever you would call them i
i think it's trying to lure me up there
for some reason
is there a hat here
i was right thank you
game design brain
please sir can i have some more
yes
i'll show them i keep just reading the
chat and then i'm just
walking into uh electrified water
um maybe i can push this charlie down
here
i don't know if the trolley was just for
that hat but surely not surely
peaky blinder my um my brother and my
housemate love peaky blind uh
i haven't watched it personally
any good
they did that on purpose that was
supposed to happen
perfect now i can use it to jump
okay ding ding can i not ring the bell
sorry
so i'm making toys here santa's workshop
i hate those monkeys
all these toys are really creepy
oh come on there's like a vent thing up
there just get up there
i don't think i can get to this window
that doesn't look okay how about you
then chair can i maybe
not move the chair really
ah so close
aha
you feel that sound was part of the game
no
am i safe is it timed or is it fine i
think it's fine
oh of course i need it on to get to the
bloody tv
so oh
maybe once we're up there we can jump oh
yeah we can we can get back over there
so we just need to
move this into place now
right let's test this out
oh it's oh oh my gosh
it's gonna be a close one guys
so
oh it's going to be so close
oh
come on
oh my gosh ah i hate this i hate the
depth i can't tell
especially when i have to set things up
myself maybe i use this
line as a as a
towel for like where to line up yes i
use the line
okay maybe the game did that on purpose
if it did then thank you
maybe it didn't but okay right that's
what we do
oh it should be the end antoine i don't
know is anyone here that has played this
game before
i was told this is like very very close
to the end
bye demo ray thanks for coming
oh sorry keep doing that i need to pay
more attention to the game
close i think yeah okay
yeah i was told last time i played that
the next playthrough would be the end
oh apparently i've still got quite a way
to go yet maybe not then maybe i'm lying
every time i play
i don't know getting closer to the end
and that's all that matters isn't it
oh it is helping me
okay
so scared i'm not gonna make it
thank you
[Music]
yes
oh everyone's gonna come running when i
do that oh god
and where am i supposed to go
[Music]
where am i supposed to hide
i don't wanna walk up to these guys all
right
am i safe with you no one's gonna
go through the fence okay
[Music]
um
oh my gosh they're coming
hi guys hey oh no
not another chase
no come on get up get up
come on where did i go where did i go i
just
didn't go anywhere okay okay let's go
this time jump up more in the middle
please
okay good boy good boy good boy good boy
you got this keep going
keep going i believe in
shoes shoes will be my downfall
shoes
no i mean on
he got his controller out so i was like
oh maybe i just turn it up
nope
hi hi
i'm not gonna turn any of the tvs off
there good distraction
go through it jump through the tv oh
crap
it's not teleport tv
um oh [ __ ] in that case then
i don't know what i'm supposed to do
okay so now i know
them off i didn't do anything
i'm gonna try and climb the tower of tvs
can't turn these off
i think i might have turned an extra one
on i'm not even quite sure what i'm
doing here
oh for [ __ ] sake let's keep dying
ugh i don't think you can run and switch
the tvs
because i'm pressing circle which is the
tv button
it doesn't do anything
all right so let's just stop for a
little bit i'm not doing anything
i don't really know
i just keep going in place
[Music]
i'm missing something important
it's not enough time to look around
though i apologies it's probably really
frustrating to watch
i'll get there in the end just gonna
figure out what to do
all right so i think i end up turning
this one on did i turn something on
i hear a noise but i don't know what i
[Music]
do
oh no i think i'm really stuck
um
it is a teleport tv oh
because i went up to it and nothing
happened
maybe i just didn't get there in time
then okay but i'm glad you told me
because i wasn't going to try that again
see he's not doing anything
he just stands there with this [ __ ]
remora
very frustrating
he just goes excuse me uh i got a tv
remote and i don't know what tv
it's for come on
stop getting stuck on invisible geometry
uh i'll try again
you know what i probably have to do uh
right trigger
but the rest of the time i've been doing
the tvs i just walk up to it and he
starts his animation so
a little bit weird
come on you got this
right come on go into the tv
why does he have his [ __ ] tv remote
out it's so annoying i just put it away
he just gets out i don't even tell him
to
is that so that's just our context
right okay just put that bloody thing
away and get in the tv
why is he just holding it like that so
frustrating
i'm pressing right trigger
right someone said maybe you need to
turn the tv on
but the tv's already on that's the
problem it's already on
but he gets out his control
and then because he's holding the
control he's it's not
doing the animation
all right someone said i gotta push my
right stick in okay so i'll push my
right stick
i push all the sticks oh crap i'm not
gonna get there in time
i want to rage queer i don't want to
play this anymore
oh thanks frank
let's go
is this broken is the game broken
is it broken i'm going to start from
checkpoint
i don't trust it i just don't feel like
it's doing anything
oh i've been doing the left stick like
the whole time
so don't worry about that
someone says that the tv isn't the
answer dante
yeah so i thought at first i thought
maybe i had to climb the tvs instead
but then i was told the tv is a teleport
tv so
come on it can't be it can't be
it can't be it really can't be
i am at the tv like literally guys i am
touching it
but he's just got his controller out
i just don't know what to do
game glitch restart the game well i just
okay i've just restarted it from the
checkpoint though
which i'm going to exit to main menu
i'll exit the main menu and then we'll
do it again we'll see if it was
a glitch you're pressing the wrong
buttons what button do i have to press
try pressing circle on there
on the button i've tried pushing both
and love sticks towards it i've tried
doing right trigger
it's gonna be all fancy i just turned it
up
it was left and right trigger
or maybe it was glitched i'm gonna say
was glitched
it was glitched guys the game was
glitched
oh my gosh that was so
irritating because throughout the game
with every time i've seen the tvs i can
literally just walk up to it
no triggers needed and it does the
teleportation so that was
really really shitty
ah thanks terry oh yeah this
this game is scary without a doubt
every character is um
very disturbed
no come out how can we get her back
[Applause]
no leave her alone it's not rain
leave her alone
oh [ __ ]
let's get the [ __ ] out of here at first
i thought i was gonna kill him and i was
like dude this is uh this is dark
oh my god oh my god this is gonna be so
close
hello you have a face and everything
you're not said the man
bye king man thanks for coming
he's walking oh god
nope nope
refuse
oh god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
i should have done this at the beginning
i should have done this i should have
done this straight away but i
started looking around the environment
that was not the time to look around the
environment
go go you can do it
you're going slow-mo again dude dude
don't don't do that what are you doing
turn around
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh sam i don't think it's the bfg come
on now
come on whenever he comes closer that's
when uh
huh how do i get
come on
oh it's so scary
this is fun
oh my god
stay for a bit oh my god thanks
ah thanksgiving with malachi [ __ ] that's
so nice of you thank you so much
oh the congrats i'm getting past the tv
my reward for sticking out and not rage
quit
thank you are you too nice dude
seriously
it's nice to know you appreciate my um
my attempts my multiple
multiple attempts and don't get bored
because uh
i would absolutely understand if you did
get bored
no thank you i don't want it
i don't want what you're selling uh how
the [ __ ] oh right
uh-oh i went a wrong way i made one
wrong turn
and that was that
[Music]
hey
bye
uh i didn't go that far from him did i
are you okay
oh no i'm really badly hurt
she's guiding me
is this what i think it is
no it's not okay never mind but i think
i'm going up to the tower
i thought it was the corridor to the
door but
this is up to the tower i'm guessing
so all the glitchy people that we've
kind of been
going through they're alive but in
like another realm or something because
she's still
in the tv well but she's here in a
glitch form
saving us or showing us the way at least
oh no we're just getting back to the
street
there it is though
whoa oh this game is so pretty
no thank you
what are you doing
whoa guys we took off our hat this is
how could we how dare we what are we
doing what is the play here
take that
give me my friend back
oh
i did something wrong but i don't really
know what i was doing anyway
do you think it was the ship
i'm supposed to be oh using my my tv
powers i get it i get
it now
it's my tv powers
oh this is so cool
i'm like breaking his bones hell yeah
you get back up and i'll get you back
down i get knocked down
no oh god okay
oh god yes
he used the force i will whisk it
[Music]
[Music]
oh
that moment beautiful so
intense here's a purple room
i love the reflections on the floor
thank you so much antoine expecto
patronum
[Music]
oh my gosh it was the same as in little
knight ms2 of the ending it was
so you just felt so powerful and
throughout the whole game you felt so
not powerful so it was just so nice to
have the power
for once
[Music]
[Music]
wow
i wish i could fly though
can i get the kettle come on
[Music]
i know i'm supposed to be going
somewhere i'm just right let's just go
[Music]
you messing with me you messing with me
room
[Music]
oh wow
this is like alice in wonderland vibes
did i just see that did i just see a
shallow go into the other room
i'm pretty sure i did
is it me it's me it's me
that was so cool i thought it was like
gonna be something spooky
but it was me oh that's that's really
really super cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so i think i'm trying to follow the
music
but i do have my headphones on the right
right eye
yeah um it's coming from this door but
then if i go
into it
then i just go back here i can't hear
anymore
[Music]
let's go again oh now it's coming from
this way
i can't go in this door can i
oh it did work okay
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
this is so trippy this game just
surprises me
every time i play i'm like oh yeah this
is completely new
oh look it's me hey it's like portal all
over again
just spent forever looking at shell from
like different angles
oh yeah i can't follow my soul i don't
have a soul
very true death
[Music]
where are you coming from
there is no cake looking is a lie
oh why did i do that
oh it's a glitch the platform was
missing what the hell
i'm sorry little one
hmm oh we need to push it push it back
right okay hopefully yeah we'll push
this one
so we can go across
[Music]
[Music]
oh actually i think it was over that
side
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
um
boy i'm just gonna have a look up here
i'll probably have to go up here soon
anyway
fine
[Music]
so
what
that can't be our friend uh
how did you get so big are you okay are
you
what
are you gonna kill me
can you hold my hand again
no why are you so big
what i'm so confused
whoa
oh wait how's she been turned into like
a monster thing i thought this was a
prequel i'm so confused
unless we get to save her okay well i'll
save you don't worry
what's this [ __ ]
can i not knock the door down
what do i have to knock down
this
that's not very nice of me are you
knocked down her music
oh no she hates me now she hates me now
she hates me now
[ __ ] okay this is gonna be difficult
uh yeah strap in boys and girls
i thought she was still gonna like
escape with me
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
so close
go go go go go go go go go go just run
your
moose
[Music]
you're a bloody moose
no no no thank you
no no no no her foot is smooth
her face through the thing
for [ __ ] sake she's got that bloody
music box
right you guys are saying she's
possessed by the music box that makes
sense
a bit like the tvs
ah there is no scafe
oh that was cool
[Music]
oh super talk now
something's gonna happen though it
always comes in threes
hello
come on we've got to get out of here
stop your whining
oh such a little brownie
ah
oh [ __ ] nearly
oh so weird
um poor little boy
i just instinctively go left
let's go this way instead
go left i'm being bright
it's falling to bits we need to get out
of here what are you doing
you're crazy
[Music]
stead
sorry i thought it was a cutscene it
looked so good
[Music]
yes we got a bag
oh thank god
oh hold on
you gotta go oh [ __ ] wait no i mean this
way
we gotta go this way
oh god come on come on come on
come on come on when i do these my
finger gets so sweaty that i just
it comes off the uh stick
oh no i think i did
i did better i thought it was going to
do then to be honest
come on let's go
come on
come on just jump
jump just jump jump
jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump
jump
jump jump jump jump jump just keep
jumping keep jumping
just keep jumping jump jump jump jump
jump jump jump jump jump jump
jump in jump crap jump run
jump run grab jump crap
run run run run
get in the right depth get up
get up boy
oh gosh i'm so far behind oh no oh no oh
no
no i'm not gonna make it give me your
hands
don't don't drop me please
[Music]
i saved you
[Music]
after all i did
i was wondering where he was in in the
first game
if this is a prequel which it seems like
very much so
i have to look into it after this
i'm not dead though
tell you what i'm gonna find a way out
of this place i'm gonna hunt her down
why did she do that to me we were
friends
oh hello
i have a chair
oh no
wow
it's all grown up how was his clothes
stretched with him
[Music]
hello is this going to be someone from
the original game
are you going to grow into the tall man
[Music]
he's like replaced the tall man
[Music]
no
[Music]
why
[Music]
what
[Music]
hmm
that was sad ending
the um the messages stopped updating so
i'll just have to go down
confusing ending you telling me why
did she are there multiple endings does
anyone know if there's multiple endings
young is like i just
there's so many questions that i
need answered like right now i'm gonna
have to go away and just watch loads of
um
videos explaining stuff to me moral of
the story
don't trust your friends like this was a
prequel right
um there is an after credit scene okay
that might help clear things up so i'll
watch that
um but i mean in the first game
uh six wasn't entirely great
i mean she ate the little elf thing and
then she ended up
she had powers um
i don't know why she would do that to
him though like he went in there to save
her
[Music]
apparently there's a secret ending
yeah six needs to get to the ship
yeah exactly so that would be after this
ah apparently um there's only
a scene after the credits if i got all
the echoes which i
doubt i got all of them i'll i'll check
anyway i'll stay here until the end of
the credits
um but i implore you all if we don't see
it but you probably won't
go and take a look at these extra
videos i i will do the same
but oh damn oh thanks for watching from
chile
david um
[Music]
that was a ride honestly this was one of
the
best horror games i've played in ages
um one of the best games i've played in
ages as well to be honest
i really really enjoyed this there was
obviously some things that
i got annoyed at just just like in the
first game obviously the depth is one of
them
and that tv thing just didn't make any
sense don't don't tell me i can make
something happen with one interaction
and then i can't do the same like in a
specific moment that doesn't make any
sense but
everything else um they nail atmosphere
they really do
and that's not just visual atmosphere
but also
um with the pacing of the game as well
they do such a good job of
of mixing in moments of like tense
tension and anxiety
um but then they give you moments of
calm
[Music]
and it's not always you know
super scary taking itself like super
seriously
which i enjoy as well um you have
your moments of calm and and then that's
when you can be
um taken off guard again and brought
back into the
fear zone you know i mean it's not just
like the whole game is super spoopy
and i've always got to be running away
or hiding from something
um there's a lot to explore and i also
what i like about this game is that
its narrative is so freaking weird and
very out there and i'm very confused
but now i want to go and explore more
and uh
i feel like they do that on purpose like
they've left it up to
sort of interpretation i'm sure they
they obviously have a narrative they
wanted to tell
but they didn't just shove it in your
face and say you know
this is what it is this is what this
means and
explain absolutely everything there's a
mystery to it
and um i mean the art style is quite
like it anyway but that's very like
cthulhu-esque
because it'll give a rough idea
of the monster or you know
the the scary thing so like cthulhu or
whatever
it would be the the being from an
alternate universe it will give you an
idea of what that is and
and more that the scale of um
of house how large and how ethereal
and terrifying it is but it won't really
give you the specifics
on exactly what it looks like exactly
what it does exactly why it's here
and that's what keeps it so so
terrifying because like
you just don't know and nothing's going
to be more scary than what you make up
in your own mind
oh yeah and the puzzles the puzzles are
really good i feel like um there were
some puzzles that i was like damn i'm
being stupid
but i don't feel like it ever went on
too long for me to feel like
very angry or annoyed by them and there
was
uh i i felt like they were all very
logical as well sometimes especially in
like survival horror games some of the
puzzles can be kind of
or in adventure games either naturally
some of the puzzles can be like
really i would never have thought of of
combining
this with that you know um
but this game wasn't like that it was
all quite intuitive
music is amazeballs check out the pale
city tv music
okay
yeah i guess that's true there's some
puzzles with dev logic
whether the sequence of actions isn't
too
clear i guess like near the end i guess
like the whole following the music thing
but i feel like
even if you aren't a dev or haven't come
across that mechanic before
you'll eventually kind of get it because
it was very obvious
once you realize because you would go
towards the doors and there would be
hardly any music and you go towards one
door and the music just be blasting at
you
and eventually you'd be like oh right
this is a very obvious
um hint of where i'm supposed to go
i agree king man definitely the best
story driven game
in a long time yes
oh very good question david what will i
play next
i don't know that's a very good question
i mean
so next week actually i said i was gonna
stream didn't i but i probably
won't stream because i am moving house
next weekend so i'm probably gonna be
busy like
packing and stuff if i stream it'll
probably just be maybe
me playing some songs for you chatting
to you
um but
yeah if i if i don't then that'll be why
follow me on discord or on twitter or on
instagram
probably not instagram much they don't
talk about their streams on instagram
but you can follow me on instagram if
you want but
follow me on twitter or discord and then
you'll you'll know whether i'll be
streaming or not
but the week after who knows
i don't think there's going to be a
credit scene it's going on for so long
oh someone's called mono didn't deserve
it ah
sad times mona didn't deserve it
so what i thought was gonna happen was
that mono was gonna turn
into um the guy with long arms from the
first game
and i'd be like oh my gosh he's the
first
scary dude that we came across but he's
not him
is he is he's the tall man that tall man
wasn't in
the little nightmares the first one was
it
i need to see more often whenever i get
more time deaf i will stream more often
i'll try i'll try
once a week now works for my schedule i
think
oh i'm also working on a new video for
you guys
uh it's gonna be like a game design
commentary on fixed camera angles i've
i've filmed it all
and started to edit it i just need to
like um get clips together
and then edit it better you know
um i might do a room tour i don't know
i'm honestly very aware
of my youtube channel now uh i think i
spoke about it around christmas because
like i've got my job now
uh i want to start being more like
professional
on youtube so less about my life and
more about
like game development and game design
and
my cinematics and my creations i thought
i might do
a video on the evolution of like my
gaming setup i thought that could be
interesting so
i could show you my studio in that video
first the chick from titanic like jacko
and now we have six
doing the the same shameful shameful
what is six's deal i don't know
but yeah i was because i was thinking
about it today i was thinking about how
my stream has like evolved over the
years and
it's actually been crazy because i
started on playstation i started on
playstation 4
and then it went from a playstation 4 to
like
a crappy macbook to them my laptop
uh my gaming laptop and now this
and yeah in the new place i'll have my
whole entire like
a whole room to to stream and work and
do everything so that'll be really
really fun and i'll definitely share
that with you
i don't think anything is
going to happen
here
probably not
oh cool david makes games too with unity
is c sharp
cool i'm uh working in
unreal engine at the moment
[Music]
no i didn't even show off my new pc
sydney
so i probably i'd need to do that at
some point
right now though honestly i'm just i'm
pretty overwhelmed with the
house move there's so much that i have
to do i'm like oh
i just want i just wanted to be over i
just want to be there now with all my
stuff and just be like
boom done yay sorted
but no it's gonna take a few weeks to
get sorted
but it's all right it'll be worth it
when i get in there it'll be so worth it
i can't wait
okay this isn't gonna
i'm not gonna get any anything because
i'm pretty sure i didn't get all the um
all the glitches and this has gone on
for ages i'm sure it would have
i'm sure it would have um happened by
now
but you know my opinion on the game i
really enjoyed it
and it looks like you guys really
enjoyed it too so thank you so much for
joining me
through this journey go now and find
the extra video and what if you want to
you don't have to
but i'm sure i'll answer a lot of
questions that you have i know i'm going
to do that
later on as well
oh it's it's made it unreal
using y's for the audio
yeah dasta
okay i will see you guys
hopefully next week if not the week
after but make sure you're following me
on
twitter and discord to be kept up to
date on
everything i'll put it